all we got to do is realize that as  human beings we have addictions  and those that are serious and  uh doing damage to us we need to control  and control medically this was all  initiated by richard nixon  he wanted to punish the black people and  also he wanted to punish the anti-war  group he moved cannabis to a schedule  one  which treated it like all other drugs  the whole problem with  addiction is a public health problem  it's not a criminal problem  and so the the tragedy is that we lock  up more people in jail  than any other country and and so here  we have people  that that are put in jail to suffer  unbelievable consequences in their  personal lives  the answer is to treat the drug and the  addiction  like an illness like a problem rather  than a criminal problem  it's a public health problem